my name is patty Jenkins and I'm the
director of Wonder Woman this scene is
where Diana from at the mascara who is a
princess from Amazonian Islands is
brought to our shores for the first time
Diana who will eventually become our
Wonder Woman is played by gal gadot and
she's brought here by Steve Trevor
played by Chris Pine so this section of
the movie one of the delightful things I
saw an opportunity to do was Oh Maj one
of my favorite movies of all time huge
inspiration to this film Richard Donner
Superman so one of the things I loved in
Superman was this very play for a period
of time where we know who Superman is
and what he can do but he's like let
loose on New York City
metropolis man's world and like in
counts of mugging which he's completely
ill-prepared for but of course in that
movie Lois Lane knows exactly what's
going on and is kind of trying to handle
the situation and he catches a bullet in
this case a similar scenario happens a
gun goes off and Wonder Woman without
even knowing what she can do Diana's
armed jets out and she blocks the bullet
saving Steve Trevor
who same shot catches the bullet in his
hand and I just found it hilarious to
have it the same kind of scene where the
two people are both trying to protect
each other and in both cases the
superpowers comes as a surprise
and then I think for Trevor's character
it's like watching you know this thing
escalate and unfold how very powerful
she is when she really puts her mind to
it
tough luck is there anything else you
wanna show me hey youtubers is Charlie
so Wonder Woman Easter Egg video clearly
you can see Superman is a big influence
on the film because the movies already
out I'm going to switch the giveaway
back to the flash ring so all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video so this is what
that Superman seen was taken from it
happened really early in the Daily
Planet and it was just a little bit
sillier in the Superman movie just
because of that tone but interesting
fact Richard Donner was credited with
creating the modern superhero movie as
it exists now he's being honored for
this big industry award people from
Marvel like Kevin Feige and DC Geoff
Johns they're all coming so not only did
Richard Donner create the modern
superhero film which is now influencing
the tone of Wonder Woman but he also
brings Marvel and DC together uniting
everyone and I almost forgot because
patty Jenkins didn't reference it in
that earlier clip but the other Superman
reference which is from before this
scene it was like two scenes
back-to-back referencing that Superman
film yep that's not gonna work please
put the sword down it doesn't go with
the outfit at all but the rest of the
Easter Egg so obviously there's the
origin story I was made from a lump of
clay that's the original version of her
origin story from the comics the new 52
retcon bat and made her the direct
descendant of Zeus and Hippolyta a
full-blown demigod you slowly see her
start to unlock her powers as she faces
new challenges through the movie the
first time she smacks her gauntlets
together and creates that big blast wave
in the comics the gauntlets are actually
there to dampen her powers so she
wouldn't tear through people like tissue
paper just walking by accidentally
brushing them that's how powerful she is
but you may have recognized that this is
Artemis she's being played by an wolf
probably one of the greatest female
fighters in history so they just made
her a badass in the movie because she
was already a badass in real life but
all those big Amazon training scenes in
the early film the big fight scenes were
done by highly trained fighters this is
Wonder Woman stunt double showing that
she can do all this stuff without any
slow motion that's how badass a fighter
she is Lewis tan posted this
behind-the-scenes video of them training
you may remember him from all the
drunken master scenes during iron fist
you may have spotted Zack Snyder's cameo
if you look really hard he was one of
the soldiers after they liberated the
town during that no man's land scene the
lasso of Hestia is kind of funny because
Hestia isn't the goddess of truth she's
the goddess of the hearts like the
fireplace so that's probably why they
have Steve Trevor talking about wife's
getting super hot as he's trying to
resist it the group that they recruit
are actually called the Black Hawks in
the comics but they were formed during
World War two so there are a couple of
changes to them but they are a wartime
group just like the Howling Commandos
there wasn't a whole lot of the Wonder
Woman TV show in it but there was a
character from the Wonder Woman TV show
that popped up during the
Galla sequences called Fausta Grable's
played by Rachel pickup she played that
character on the original Wonder Woman
TV show she was just like a Nazi
operative so she showed up during these
scenes when Ares says that he's not the
God of War he's the God of truth that's
actually from a Gail Simone Wonder Woman
arc it was like a line in number 37 I
think a couple years ago where he says
war is truth princess by all rights this
should belong to me during their big
battle the first time that Wonder Woman
actually started using lightning based
powers was Wonder Woman number 39 also
part of that Gail Simone Rudd but the
way they explain it is is that her
gauntlets were given to her by Zeus they
enable her to channel the lightning so
her gauntlets are key to that ability
the movies intro the voiceover that she
has where she talks about the beautiful
planet wanting to save it that's
actually ripped right out of DC rebirth
the ice cream is right out of Justice
League number one from Gimli they also
did it during Justice League war and she
did hook a tank during the injustice
comic-like areas as looking at her hair
did you just Chuck a tank but Superman
also does it during the Dark Knight
Returns comic we know that the Dark
Knight Returns Frank Miller is very
influential in the DC EU so you could
take it either way when Chris Pine walks
in and says where are we at right now
while she's trying outfits on and edit
candy replies outfit number 226 that's a
reference to the end of Greg ruckus run
number 226 was his last issue he wrote
on a for a long time and here's a bit of
a Deathstroke Easter Egg the god killer
sword is something that he gains
possession of it's a sword that actually
exists in the comics Wonder Woman
doesn't wield it herself but it does
have special powers when you kill a God
with it it transfers their powers and
their memories to you is actually a
pretty big deal and it can reform itself
if it's ever destroyed so I know a lot
of people are like which sword was
Wonder Woman using during Batman V
Superman if the god killer was destroyed
by Ares so either they're doing the
comic book thing where the sword reforms
itself or she's just using a different
mythical sword when we get to Batman V
Superman so let me know in the comments
if you spotted any other Easter eggs in
the movie there's some new infinity war
Captain America black panther stuff from
behind the scenes so I'll probably do a
video for that next but leave all your
requests for DC videos and the
comments below between the TV shows and
movies I'll say congratulations to
chimichanga you're the latest giveaway
winner please private message me so I
can get your contact details there was a
new round in this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
a DC video you can click here for brand
new flash season 4 you can click here
for the most epic of Batman twists in
the comics in a long long time
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys tonight
you